juicy happy new year good to see you new
year carlos nice to see you
what a cool way to kick off 2021 by
being the first
black bat woman by being like a
superhero
like it must be super cool even to just
say that
still right yeah definitely definitely
i mean we grew up watching superheroes
so be to be able to
at any point in my career say i played a
superhero
pretty freaking epic was this a goal of
yours when you
you know started acting that you're like
i want to be in a position where i get
to
um have this kind of influence on people
and have this kind of almost this kind
of responsibility too like as a
superhero
it's your the idea is like a lot of
people will look up to you
definitely um it's funny because i did a
a
podcast interview in may before i even
knew about the role
being recast and um they
the interviewer asked me what was like
my next dream
job and i told him i said my next dream
job is to play a superhero
and it's crazy because less than a month
later i'm auditioning for batwoman
um and so i i never expected it but i
did
i know i believe in i believe in
manifestation and so
i knew that i would play some kind of
superhero at one point in my career
um i just didn't expect it to happen so
quick after i said it i didn't expect
him to be
a part of one of the most epic
franchises that have
that has ever existed um so to be on
that journey
with the batman batman franchise is
super
fun and and such an honor and then as
far as
um the responsibility you know i think
that
one of my goals always was to be able to
use my art
as activism and to play this role that
kind of is like
they're very much in alignment with each
other
you know you shared recently that um the
announcement
of you being batwoman first black bat
woman
was also a part of your own coming out
story uh
do you feel a stronger connection to the
character because of that
um you know i didn't
i where i came from it's just very much
um
i'm from upper marlboro maryland i'm
like 15 minutes out of washington dc
um so the representation of the queer
community
is very like it's very represented there
we are um you know it's just it's not we
don't there doesn't have to be this
journey of like
finding your voice because that is like
they're
i feel like lgbtq being black being
being a person of color being a woman is
just so represented where i'm from
so it's more so moving into a space of
entertainment
i felt brave always about who i was
um i never felt like there was this like
journey of coming out i felt like
i've always walked in my truth and um
when necessary i would have a
conversation but it never
felt like i had to come out but my
mother and i had never had a
conversation
so i was just like you know i know you
know it's different when you're talking
to your mother about stuff i don't talk
to my mother about anything that has to
do with like
um you know that stuff in general
to her i'm like a good girl i don't do
anything
because i just don't talk about that
kind of stuff with my mom i'm always
like intrigued when i see
you know um people talk to their parents
about anything like that because i've
always just been
very um private about you know all of
that private about
private so i wanted to talk to her
because i
didn't want her to feel as though she
was finding something out after everyone
else
you know and so when i sat down and
talked to her she just was like
look you're my daughter there's nothing
about you that i don't know
um so just understand that i love you
and i am always here and i'm always in
your corner and i will always back you
up
and so it was all i needed to feel brave
enough to just continue to walk in my
truth
i love that i love that one of the cool
things that i love as a fan
about uh these superhero stories the dc
ones too is the idea of like this
multiverse thing
where all these different crossovers can
happen now
in the movies we've seen a lot of
different um actors take on the role of
batman
in like a dream scenario which batman
would you love your bat woman to team up
with
gosh
i hate when god when you guys make me
pick
so i always say this when it comes to um
the world of batman it's not always been
about the actual batman and it's
actually been more about the super
villains that surround batman
so like usually what makes me have a
favorite batman is based off of the
super villains more than it is
the actual actor that plays batman i
think all the actors have done an
amazing job
um but i think that if i had to only
pick based off of the actor i would
probably pick val kilmer's
uh batman just because i think he did
this great job of playing like bruce
wayne
and batman you know like he gave bruce
wayne
some layers that i hadn't seen before um
and he was also just like this really
epic batman
but then again you're talking about um
um
you're you're talking about like these
colorful villains that got to play in
his world
because tim burton did such a great job
really creating this like
this imaginative world of gotham where
you saw it almost
at times looked like outer space where
you saw things floating
and you just saw like this like epicness
that surrounded just this
this really dope batman um so if i had
to pick i'd pick val's batman to play
with
yeah um but then i i look at the more
you know the the the more recent batman
um trilogies are you look at heath
ledger's
joker and i mean that was epic so then
i'm like oh man i would love to play in
christian bells batman because then i
get to
work with characters like that so it's
hard to pick and
i i love them all for different reasons
so the answers bring them all on
that's the answer all of them bring them
all on
the answer is come on let me play with
jim carrey and danny devito and
you know uh um uh tom hardy like yes
let's play with all of them that's
awesome well i know for sure the fans
are gonna love the fact that you can
talk about it for hours too
so you know thank you so much for your
time here and i'm looking forward to
more
of what you know your bat woman is going
to bring
thank you thank you for having me